welcome everyone this is part five in
our series on methods and metrics we're
going to be talking about essential
selected topics in model evaluation in
our field
here's our overview i'd like to start by
talking about baselines and their role
in experimental comparisons
then we'll discuss hyper parameter
optimization both the process and the
motivations as well as compromises that
you might have to make due to resource
constraints and other constraints
we'll touch briefly on classifier
comparison which is a topic we covered
in the sentiment analysis unit
and then we'll close with two topics
that are really pressing for deep
learning models which is
assessing models without convergence and
the role of random parameter
initialization in shaping experimental
results
so let's begin with baselines
the fundamental insight here is that in
our field evaluation numbers can never
be understood properly in isolation
let's consider two extreme cases suppose
your system gets 0.95 f1 then you might
feel like you can declare victory at
that point
but it will be natural for people who
are consuming your results to ask well
is the task too easy is it really an
achievement that you got .95 or would
even simpler systems have
achieved something similar
at the other end of the spectrum suppose
your system gets 0.6 f1 you might think
that that means you haven't gotten
traction but we should ask two questions
first what do humans get as a kind of
upper bound and also what would a random
classifier get and if your 0.6 is really
different from the random classifier and
human performance is kind of low we
might then see that this point six f1 is
a real achievement
that kind of shows you that bass lines
are just crucial for strong experiments
in our field so defining bass lines for
you should not be an afterthought but
rather central to how you define your
overall hypothesis
baselines are really important for
building a persuasive case and they can
be used to eliminate specific aspects of
the problem that you're tackling and
specific virtues of your proposed system
what this really comes down to is right
from the start you might be saying for
example here's a baseline model here's
my proposed modification of it and the
way we test your hypothesis is by
comparing the performance of those two
systems in that context you can see that
the baseline is playing a crucial role
in quantifying the extent to which your
hypothesis is true and therefore careful
model for comparisons at that level are
going to be really fundamental to the to
successful pursuit of the hypothesis
when in doubt you could include random
baselines in your results table they're
very easy to set up and can illuminate
what it's like if we're just making
random predictions and here i'm showing
you that scikit-learn kind of has you
covered on this point they have two
classes dummy classifier and dummy
regressor each with a wide range of
different ways that they can make random
guesses based on the data
and i would encourage you to use these
classes because it will make it easy for
you to fit the random baselines into
your overall experimental pipeline which
will reduce the amount of code that you
have to write and possibly avoid bugs
that might come from implementing these
baselines yourself so strongly
encouraged
and kind of at the other end of the
spectrum you might think for your task
whether there are tasks specific
baselines that you should be considering
because they might reveal something
about the data set or the problem or the
way people are going about modeling the
problem we saw an example of this before
in the context of natural language
inference we saw that hypothesis only
baselines tended to make predictions
that were as good as 0.65 to 0.70 f1
which is substantially better than the
baseline random chance would which would
be at about 0.33
and that's revealing to us that when we
measure performance we should really be
thinking about gains above that
hypothesis only baseline comparisons
against random chance are going to
vastly overstate the extent to which we
have made meaningful progress on those
data sets
the story of the story close task is
somewhat similar here the task is to
distinguish between a coherent and
incoherent ending for a story
and people observed that systems that
looked only at the ending options were
able to do really well there is some
bias in coherent and incoherent
continuations that leads them to be
pretty good evidence for making this
classification decision
again you might think that that reveals
that there's a fundamental problem with
the data set and that might be true but
another perspective is simply that when
we do comparisons and think about model
performance it should be with this as
the baseline and not random guessing
okay let's talk about hyper parameter
optimization we discussed this in our
unit on sentiment analysis and we walk
through some of the rationale let me
quickly reiterate the full case for this
first hyperparameter optimization might
be crucial for obtaining the best
version of your model that you can which
might be your fundamental goal
probably for any modern model that
you're looking at there are it's a wide
range of hyper parameters and we might
know that different settings of them
lead to very different outcomes so it's
in your best interest to do hyper
parameter search to put your model in
the very best light
we also talked at length about how this
is a crucial step in conducting fair
comparisons between models it's really
important that when you conduct a
comparison you not put one model in its
best light with its best hyper parameter
settings and have all the other models
be kind of randomly chosen or even
poorly chosen hyper parameter settings
because that would lead to unfair
comparisons and exaggerate differences
between the models what we want to do is
compare the models all with their best
possible hyper parameter settings and
that implies doing extensive search to
find those settings
and the third motivation you might have
is just to understand the stability of
your architecture we might want to know
for some large space of hyper parameters
which ones really matter for final
performance maybe which ones lead to
really degenerate solutions and which
space of hyper parameters overall
perform the best so that we have more
than just a single set of parameters
that work well but maybe real insights
into the overall settings of the models
that are really good
there's one more rule that i need to
reiterate here
all hyperparameter tuning must be done
only on train and development data it is
a sin in our field to do any kind of
hyper-perimeter tuning on a test set
all that tuning should happen outside of
the test set and then as usual you get
one run on the test set with your chosen
parameters and that is the number that
you report as performance on the test
data
that's the only way that we can really
get a look at how these systems behave
on completely unseen data so this is
really crucial for
understanding progress in our field
now hyper parameter optimization as you
can imagine can get very expensive let's
review that and then talk about some
compromises right the ideal for hyper
parameter optimization is that you
identify a large set of values for your
model
you create a list of all the
combinations of those values this will
be the cross product of all the values
of the features that you identified
then for each of the settings you should
cross validate it on the available
training data
and then choose the the settings that
did the best at step three train on all
the training data used using those
settings and then finally evaluate on
the test data that is the ideal here and
let's just think about how that's
actually going to work suppose for our
example that we have one hyperparameter
and it has five values
and we have a second hyperparameter with
ten values then the cross product is
going to lead us to have 50 total
settings for those hyper parameters
suppose we add a third hyperparameter
with two values now the number of
settings that we have has jumped up to
100.
if we want to do five-fold
cross-validation to select those optimal
parameters then we are talking about
doing 500 different experiments
that's probably perfectly fine if you're
dealing with a small linear model with
some hand built features but if you are
fitting a large transformer based model
where each experiment takes you up to
one day
this is going to be prohibitively
expensive in terms of time or compute
resources and that's going to compel us
to make some compromises this is the
bottom line here the above picture that
ideal is untenable as a set of laws for
our scientific community if we adopted
it then complex models trained on large
data sets would end up disfavored and
only the very wealthy would be able to
participate and just to give you a
glimpse of just how expensive this could
get here's a quotation from this nice
paper on nlp the machine learning for
healthcare in their supplementary
materials they report that performance
on all of the above neural networks was
tuned automatically using google vizier
with a total of over 200 000 gpu hours
for me as a private citizen that could
easily cost a half a million dollars
just for the process of hyper parameter
optimization and that's what i mean by
this being kind of fundamentally
untenable for us
so what should we do in response we need
a pragmatic response here here are some
steps that you take to alleviate the
problem in what i view as kind of
descending order of attractiveness so
starting with the best option you could
do some random sampling and maybe guided
sampling to explore a large space of
hyper parameters on a fixed
computational budget
you could do search based on just a few
epochs of training right rather than
allowing your model to run for many
epochs which could take a whole day you
might select hyper parameters based on
one or two epochs on the assumption that
settings that are good at the start will
remain good settings that are bad at the
start will remain bad that's a heuristic
assumption but it seems reasonable you
could possibly bolster it with some
learning curves and so forth and that
could vastly cut down on the amount that
you have to spend in this search process
you could also search based on subsets
of the data this would be another kind
of compromise however because a lot of
hyper parameters are dependent on data
set size i think of regularization terms
this might be riskier than the version
in two there where we just train for a
few epochs
you also might do some heuristic search
maybe by defining which hyper parameters
matter less and then set those by hand
based on this heuristic search and then
you might just describe that process in
the paper that you know via a few
observations you made some guesses about
parameters that you could fix and
therefore explored a smaller subset of
the space that you might have liked to
explore
again i think if you make the case and
you're clear about this readers will be
receptive because we're aware of the
costs
you could also find optimal hyper
parameters via a single split of your
data and use them for all subsequent
splits
that would be justified if the splits
are very similar and your model
performance is very stable and that
would reduce all that cross validation
that did cause the number of experiments
we had to run to jump up by a large
amount
and finally you might adopt others
choices
now the skeptic will complain that these
findings don't translate to new data
sets but it could be the only option
that you just observe for example that
for some very large model the original
authors use settings x y and z and you
might simply adopt them even knowing
that your data set or your test might
call for different optimal settings
it isn't the best but if it's the only
thing that you can afford
it's certainly a reasonable case to make
finally some tools for hyper parameter
search as usual scikit-learn has a bunch
of great tools for this grid search
randomized search and halving grid
search
grid search will be the most expensive
randomized search the least expensive
and halving grid search will help you
kind of strategically navigate through
the space
of hyper parameters and if you want to
go even further in that direction the
scikit optimize
package offers a bunch of tools for
doing
model based performance driven
exploration of a space of hyper
parameters and that could be very
effective indeed
all right let's talk briefly about
classifier comparison we've it's a topic
we've reviewed before but i'll just
briefly recap the scenario is this
suppose you've assessed two classifier
models their performance is probably
different to some degree numerically
what can be done to establish whether
those models are different in some
meaningful sense
as we've discussed i think guidance from
the literature is that first we could
cover practical differences if you just
observe that one model makes 10 000 more
highly important predictions than
another then that might be sufficient to
make the case that it's the better model
for differences that are narrower again
the good the guidance is that we might
use confidence intervals uh on repeated
runs are the wilcoxon signed ranked test
to get a single summary statistic of
whether or not the different runs are
truly different in their means and
variants
you could use mcneemar's test if you can
only afford to run one experiment
whereas the wilcoxon and confidence
intervals will require you to run 10 to
20 different experiments which again
could be prohibitively expensive and in
those situations you might fall back to
mcneemar's test because it's less
expensive and arguably better than
nothing especially in scenarios where
it's hard to tell whether there are
practical differences between the
systems
finally let's talk about two topics that
seem especially pressing in the context
of large-scale deep learning models and
the first is assessing models without
convergence
right when working with linear models
convergence issues rarely arise because
the models seem to converge quickly
based on whatever threshold you've set
and convergence implies kind of maximize
performance in a wide range of cases
with neural networks however convergence
issues really take center stage the
models rarely converge even based on
liberal thresholds that you might set
they converge at different rates between
runs so it's hard to predict and their
performance on the test data is awfully
heavily often heavily dependent on these
differences right sometimes a model with
a low final error turns out to be great
and sometimes sometimes it turns out to
be worse than one that finished with a
higher error who really knows what's
going on
our only fall back in these situations
is just to just do experiments and
observe what seems to work the best
so i think a very natural and easy to
implement response to this that proves
highly effective is what i'm calling
here incremental dev set testing this is
just the idea that as training proceeds
we will regularly collect information
about performance on some held out dev
set as part of the training process for
example at every 100th iteration you
could make predictions on that dev set
and store those predictions for some
kind of assessment
all the pi torch models for our course
have an early stopping parameter that
will allow you to conduct experiments in
this way and keep hold of what seemed to
be the best model performance wise and
then report that
based on the stopping criteria that you
set up and with lock heuristically that
will give you the best model in the
fewest epochs
the early stopping parameter has a bunch
of different other settings that you can
use to control exactly how it behaves
which might be important for particular
model structures or data sets
here's a bit of
motivation for early stopping you might
be thinking why not just let my model
run to convergence if i possibly can
in the context of these large
very difficult optimization processes
that could lead you really far astray
right so here is a picture of a deep
learning model and you can see its error
going down very quickly over many
iterations and it looks like you might
want to iterate out even to 80 epochs of
training
however if you look at performance on
that held up dev set you see that this
model actually very quickly reached its
peak of performance and then all that
remaining training was just was training
was just either wasting time or eroding
the performance that you saw early on in
the process and this is exactly why
since this is our real goal here you
might want to do some kind of dev step
dev set testing with early stopping
the final thing i'd want to say here is
that all of this might lead us to get
out of the mode of assuming that we
should always be reporting one number to
summarize our models we're dealing with
very powerful models in the limit they
might be able to learn very complicated
things and we might want to want to ask
different questions like how quickly can
they learn and how effectively and how
robustly and that might imply that what
we really want to do is not report
summary tables of statistics but rather
full learning curves with confidence
intervals this is a picture from a paper
that i was involved with but i think
it's illuminating to see a by category
breakdown of how the model is performing
in addition to the overall average
because you can see that while this red
model is arguably much better than the
yellow and the gray overall
it's kind of hard to distinguish it
globally from this blue model but for
various of the subcategories you do see
some differences whereas for others you
do see that they're kind of
indistinguishable it's a very rich
picture you can also see that early on
for some of these categories some of
these models are really differentiated
they learn more efficiently
whereas by the time you've run out to
100 000 epochs many of the model
distinctions have disappeared
that's the kind of rich picture that is
already giving us a sense for how
different values and different goals we
have might guide different choices about
which model to use and different choices
about how to optimize and i would just
love it if our field got into the habit
of reporting this very full picture as
opposed to reducing everything to a
single number
the final topic is the role of random
parameter initialization this is kind of
yet another hyper parameter that's in
the background that's much more
difficult to think about
most deep learning models have their
parameters initialized randomly or many
of those parameters are initialized
randomly
this is clearly meaningful for these
non-convex optimization problems that
we're posing but even simple models can
also be impacted if you're dealing with
very small data sets with very large
feature spaces
in this classic paper here these authors
just observe that different
initializations for neural sequence
models that were doing named entity
recognition
led to statistically significantly
different results that is one in the
same model with a different random seed
was performing in ways that looked
significantly different on these data
sets and a number of recent systems
actually turned out to be
indistinguishable in terms of their raw
performance
once this source of variation was taken
into account that's just a powerful
example of how much a random seed could
shape final performance in the context
of models like this
relatedly at the other end of the
spectrum you can see catastrophic
failure as a result of unlucky
initialization some settings are great
and some can be miserable failures
we don't really know ahead of time which
will be which
and that means that we just have to be
really attentive to how we're
initializing these systems in a wide
range of settings and you'll notice that
in the evaluation methods notebook that
i've distributed as a companion to this
lecture i fit a simple feed forward
network a very small one on the classic
xor problem which is one of the original
motivating problems for using deep
learning models at all and what you see
is that it succeeds about eight out of
ten times where the only thing that
we're changing across these models is
the way they are randomly initialized
and that again just shows you that this
can be powerfully shaping
final performance for our systems and
probably what we need to do is be
thinking about this as yet another hyper
parameter that we need to tune and
optimize along with all the rest
you